this is one I caught wind of late Friday
afternoon early evening and it generated
a ton of buzz into Friday night and
Saturday which is hard to do this time
of year on a weekend the idea that the
Jets there's a rumor and I want to be
very careful out of couch and we're not
reporting that the Jets are doing it but
in league circles people who are working
in football are talking about the Jets
wanting Peyton Manning to be the next
general manager or whatever title he
would have but VP of football operation
whatever it would be but the leader of
the franchise that Christopher Johnson
seems to be looking for Johnson said
last week after firing GM Mike McKagan
he wants a great strategic thinker it's
more than an Italian of talent evaluator
and Peyton Manning would fit that bill
for one key reason Chris he's a guy that
I think could work very well with Adam
GaSe because they've worked together in
the past in Denver and I think Peyton
Manning could keep Adam GaSe and all
that energy and all that that that drive
and desire he has to win football games
pointed in the right direction yeah no I
don't disagree with any of that I mean I
get it and I also you know I don't you
know think it's crazy that the Jets are
thinking about a guy like Peyton Manning
I understand that that's thinking as
well I mean of course great football
mind grew up in the sport been around it
pays attention to it but you know I just
I made some calls about this and just it
doesn't sound like this is serious to me
from the people I've talked to around
the Wow yeah well right uuugh from
Peyton's perspective you have Peyton's
ready to do yes exactly I think for the
Jets tour the Jets can want him yeah
sure I can say I don't want to do it
right but you know what if Christopher
Johnson shows up with a truckload of
money and a piece of equity I mean
that's the kind of thing that's gonna
get peyton manning's attention you have
to make him an offer he can't refuse
until you do he's gonna refuse it yeah
no I agreed and yes I you know again III
don't know the Jets side of that and I
certainly wouldn't fault them for
kicking around the idea of bringing
Peyton Manning in to run your football
team I get that
I just think from the things I've heard
the optics of the situation I just don't
think Peyton Manning's ready yet I think
that's where I really look at it I do
think it's only a matter of time before
he is the vice president of football
operations or a GM of a certain football
team
definitely but you know everything I
know I think he's enjoying playing golf
and just being free right now as far as
post Peyton Manning career playing wise
and just enjoying his life but I do
think it's only a matter of time but I
do I think when Peyton decides to go
down this road though it's not gonna be
a oh gosh I haven't been paying
attention that closely to football oh
now you blew me out of the water you
know with the Brinks trunk of cash you
know up to my house and I'm gonna jump
in and be the GM I just don't think
that's the way he operates I think he'd
be the kind of guy that this is the time
of year we'd start to hear who Peyton
Manning might be interested in looking
for a job for next offseason and then he
starts to dive into the football
operations side of things during the
season to go start evaluating players
and rosters and everything like that to
get himself ready so to me this doesn't
look like a Peyton Manning move even
though I don't think it's a bad idea by
the Jets on their side what do you think
it would take to get his attention how
much money per year oh gosh I mean I you
know again yeah we're talking about the
guy that I don't know nobody's made more
money in the history of the NFL than
Peyton Manning right along with Papa
John's and all that so to me it's not
even necessarily all about money money
money in this situation I would think
he's got a lot of it and can feel
comfortable there but I don't know Mike
I have no freaking clue what is it
between 10 and 20 million dollars I
would say 20 my big 20 money and 2% of
the team would do it yeah and 2% of the
team III get that you know would the
Jets to do that I understand that I
guess the thing I always thought about
Peyton Manning is when all said and done
he's gonna go to some place that you
know fits you know who he is as a human
being like I always thought it would be
the New Orleans Saints maybe after the
Sean Payton era is over now Peyton
Manning comes in and runs the football
team or maybe the Tennessee Titans
because he was a Tennessee volunteer
there and of course he's you know
arguably the most famous guy in that
state as is because of his time at the
University of Tennessee I could see him
running that franchise but I just don't
know if the timing seems right with the
New York Jets I think a lot of the
things you made as far as you know
backing up why it would be a good fit I
totally agree with you I mean I
Peyton Manning's made for the job I
think he can handle Adam GaSe they'd
have a great working relationship
he put a positive vibe and spin on the
organization altogether it just doesn't
look like to me right now he's ready to
do that and I think for a guy like
Peyton Manning when he does something
like this he's gonna go oh god I mean
rightly totally full-time obsession yes
seven days a week and you know it was
suggested to me within the first year or
so of his retirement that he may just
retire never get back into football oh
yeah that there's like I've done my time
in football I lived that part of my life
and you know I know Tony Dunne she's a
firm believer the Peyton Manning will
never get into coaching because it will
drive him crazy not to have a
quarterback as good as Peyton Manning
well if you're up in the luxury suite
with a suit on and you're watching all
the pieces that you've put together on
the field that that could drive you
crazy yeah I don't know that that that's
far enough removed from playing yeah to
make you say okay I'm fine with this
even if that quarterback is you know not
even 20% of what I was that's the best
guy we could find and we just have to
make it work and Manny gonna be yeah
think about think about the way he will
micromanage in a good way I mean I I'm a
firm believer that whatever he chooses
to do right he will be successful at and
he will figure out how to crack the code
on putting together a great football
organization I think it'd be great for
the league get him involved in league
matters as well because I think he will
bring good ideas a relentless work ethic
to the table but that's the thing he's
got to be ready to do it and he's got to
be able to eventually take a step back
and and see how these young players can
go out and screw it up like he didn't
well I mean you made it right when he
goes all and when he wants to do it he's
gonna go all-in that's why it to me he
can't be all in right now he just can't
from everything I've heard the life he's
living you know like you said he's not
gonna feel comfortable walking into a
building and people are gonna bring up
players to him and he's not gonna have
great knowledge to talk about it so that
doesn't seem like a Peyton Manning move
there either way hey if there's a
quarterback that's gonna be burnt out a
little bit after the career come on
Peyton Manning would be that guy I mean
he lived the line of franchise
quarterback slash extension of the
coaching staff may be greater than any
quarterback we've seen here in modern
history
so I mean it was a grind for him he was
part of game planning a lot of the times
and you know all the audibles and the
things they did in the line of scrimmage
I mean man Payton had a lot on his plate
more than the normal quarterback from
the X's and O's standpoint to where he
might want to break and let's not forget
Elway hey he what was it 1314 years
before he finally jumped in was a the
Denver Broncos so you know maybe Peyton
Manning needs a little time off to be a
father and do other things in life
before he gets the the fire to jump back
in quite yet and even if a team like the
Jets would offer him 20 million in two
percent you know one of the right are
the reasons it would be easy to say no
to it
there probably be more later right you
get if that would get out there the Jets
offered it and he said no then then you
know what the price is to get Peyton
Manning and at some point somebody
whether it's the Titans whether it's the
Saints somebody is gonna put that
together cuz the one thing we always
lose sight of and I think there is I
don't want to start too far down this
rabbit hole I think there is a certain
amount of collusion when it comes to
setting what teams pay coaches because
coaching salaries haven't gone up over
the years the way player salaries have
and I think a great coach is far more
important to a team and a great player
but you know you you got Bill Belichick
in that range of 15 million-plus and
there's no salary cap and if you really
want Peyton Manning maybe maybe he's the
guy that breaks the the mold and allows
some of these other coaches and
executives to get more money if somebody
would pay him 20 million plus per year
yeah well I think that's like one of the
dirty little secrets as you know yeah
the the guys that are really successful
in the NFL at coaching or they're being
paid somehow some other way like you
said well we don't really know what Bill
Belichick's making but I think we expect
that he's making yeah probably double
what we hear about because of course
he's that important that's successful
you know that great of a model for an
organization but I've heard about this a
lot through the years even before I was
playing you know there were certain
coaches and won Super Bowls and they
were paid more than what was told to the
public by whether it was you know off
the books by the owners other businesses
however it may be and I think that goes
on in coaching to kind of keep that
price down a little bit for some of the
other guys that are in the business
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports